الحرب في اوكرانيا مر سنه على هذه الحرب
ما هو تقييمكم للوضع الانساني هناك او في
ظل هذه الحرب
ولكن
انه عندما تنظرين الى اوكرانيا الارقام
تتحدث عن نفسها لدينا ثمانيه ملايين
اوكراني لجاوا الى الخارج وحوالي 6 ملايين
نجحوا من ديارهم وهناك حوالي 17 مليون شخص
بحاجه للمساعده الانسانيه في اوكرانيا
الوضع بالغ الصعوبه ونحن متواجدون هناك
نتعاون ايضا مع الصليب الاحمر الاوكراني
وهناك امر مهم للغايه حتى يتم التخفيف من
المعاناه وهو احترام القانون الانساني
الدولي
الاتفاقيات التي تحمي العمل الانسان يجب
ان تسري وينبغي احترام هذه الاتفاقيات
والتطبيقها نحن في اللجنه الدوليه للصليب
الاحمر نحن مفوضون للدفاع
والمطالبه باحترام القانون الانساني
الدولي وهذا هو السبب الذي يجعلنا التعاون
مع السلطات في وكذلك في روسيا بشان ضروره
التقيد
بالقانون الانساني الدولي لحمايه المدنيين
وكذلك البنيه التحتيه المدنيه علاوه على
حمايه
السجناء الحرب او المعتقلين من المدنيين
هل هناك اولويات محدده بالنسبه للتعامل مع
الوضع في اوكرانيا بالنسبه لكم يعني شيء
يكون في القمه يعني تحاولون حله او اول
الاشياء
لدينا اولويه خلال فصل الشتاء الراهن الا
وهي هي ضمان ان اكثر الناس ضعفا ان يكون
لديهم ماوى وسبل الحصول على التدفئه في
شهرين يناير وفبراير ولكن لدينا اولويات
اخرى الا وهي تقديم الدعم
فيتعلق بمس
البلديات لتقديم المياه الصالحه للشرب
والكهرباء
للمستشفيات حتى تواصل هذه الانظمه عملها
هذه اولويه عملنا عليها بالتعاون مع
البلديات والسلطات المسؤوله وهناك مسؤوليه
اخرى الا وهي
تعاون مع السلطات لحمايه المدنيين والبنيه
التحتيه المدنيه وفقا للقانون الانساني
الدولي وكذلك اتفاقيات جنيف